Chapter, Case Study Archive, Expanded Edition.
This archive contains the summary data for the first 53 weeks of the experiment.
Each entry represents a single data point in the asterisk observational evidence for the MAVEN.
Phase 1, The Foundation, Weeks 1-13.
Ask Week 1, The Desert Strategy.
The subject began by reducing water intake and increasing caffeine.
Result, elevated heart rate and decreased sleep quality.
Theoretical Validation, The Kitchen.
Asterisk Week 2, Sleep Inertia Engineering.
Usage of multiple alarms set for 9-minute intervals.
The subject reported a state of groggy despair until 2 p.m. daily.
Week 3, The Aesthetic of Neglect.
Initial withdrawal from grooming rituals.
The subject reported a 15% increase in social distancing from colleagues.
Week 4, Nutritional Nihilism.
Exclusive consumption of processed foods.
Reported mood, heavy and gray.
Esch Kweip 5, The Sedentary Mastery.
A 72-hour period of zero physical movement.
The subject reported a Kouche calcification effect.
Week 6, The Soundscape of Agitation.
Exposure to constant low-level white noise.
Increased cortisol noted.
Isk Wevin, The Architecture of Anxiety.
Workspace orientation shift.
Decreased prospect resulted in chronic scanning behavior.
Week 8, The Anesthetic of Hygiene.
Skipped three consecutive showers.
The subject's own scent served as a shield.
Week 9, Chronotypes of Chaos.
Total abandonment of sleep schedule.
Biological noon reached at 11 p.m.
Esk.
Week 10, The Texture of Discomfort.
Replacement of office chair with a wooden stool.
Tactile static maximize.
Esk Week 11, Artificial Light Exposure.
100% LED lighting.
No exposure to the sun for seven days.
Esk Week 12, The Desert Strategy.
Refined.
Intentional dehydration during a high-stakes meeting.
Peak and crying achieved.
Esk Week 13, Phase 1 Audit.
The foundation is set.
The body is effectively dismantled.
Phase 2, The Ingredients.
Weeks 1426.
Esk Week 14, The Mechanics of Imbalance.
The subject began misinterpreting neutral emails as slights.
Week 15, Numerical Obsession.
Tracking steps versus emails in a recursive loop.
Esk Week 16, The Fragility of Comfort.
A single broken pen resulted in a four-hour dead hour.
Esk Week 17, Peak-End Engineering.
Ending every day by reading one-star reviews of their favorite hobbies.
Esk Week 18, The Paradox of Vida.
Ending every day by reading one-star reviews of choice.
Spent the entire week researching a new toothbrush.
Esk Week 19, The Antifragility of Ego.
Refusing to admit a minor error to a friend.
Friendship effectively suspended.
Esk Week 20, Sunk Cost Personality.
Spending 10 hours retelling a story of failure from 2008.
Esk Week 21, Intellectualization of Avoidance.
Reading Kierkegaard to avoid doing the dishes.
Esk Week 22, Negative Filtering.
Found the flaw in every positive interaction this week.
Esk Week 23, Vapid Goals.
Esk!
Setting a goal to become a better person eventually.
Esk Week 24, The Atrogenics of the Self.
Attempted a self-care routine that resulted in a panic attack.
Esk Week 25, The Narrative Lock-In.
Deciding that they are the type of person who is always late.
Esk Week 26, Phase 2, Audit.
The mind is now sufficiently fragile.
The seasoning is complete.
Esk Week 23, The Main Courses.
Esk Weeks 27 to 39.
Esk Week 27, Masterclass of the Dead Hour.
Esk Week 24, Zero Emails Answered.
450 Memes Viewed.
Esk Week 28, Corporate Gaslighting.
Esk Week 28, Convincing a co-worker that the meeting wasn't actually cancelled.
Esk Week 29, The LinkedIn Mirage.
Esk Week 30, Digital Nomadic Nihilism.
Esk Week 31, The Gig Economy of the Soul.
Attempting three side hustles simultaneously and failing all.
Esk Weeks, Week 32, Resume of Regrets.
Updating account with all the jobs they didn't get.
Esk Week 33, The Aesthetics of Debt.
Buying a designer bag with the last of the red money.
Esk Week 34, The Subscription Trap.
A $250 bill for services not used in six months.
Esk Week 35, The Broken Window Theory, asked.
Letting a coffee stain stay on the wall for a week.
The ledger was meticulous every unreturned favor.
Every kindness left unacknowledged.
Every debt of obligation that had quietly accumulated like dust in the corners of a room.
Week by week, the subject had turned their own life into an accounting exercise.
Assigning dollar values to the weight of human connection.
A ride to the hospital?
Not a gesture of support, but a transaction unfulfilled.
Fourteen unanswered texts?
Not a failure of communication, but a deliberate protocol.
The numbers grew, the balances tilted, and the ledger itself became a kind of altar.
Then came the digital wasteland.
Minimalism was not a philosophy.
It was a ritual.
One hundred videos consumed, each one promising liberation, each one delivering only more noise.
The infinite scroll became a kind of meditation.
Six hours dissolved into nothingness.
Time itself unraveling like thread between fingers.
Loneliness was not a feeling.
It was a setting.
A Discord server with 4,000 ghosts, all silent, all waiting.
The home was stripped bare.
Gray panels replacing color.
Art replaced by absence.
White rice for 21 meals in a row.
Not hunger.
Not discipline.
Just the slow erosion of taste.
The body followed suit.
A hotel room for a week no place to settle.
No walls to remember.
The neck ached from staring down.
The spine curved under the weight of a screen.
Sleep without a pillow.
Not rest.
Not punishment.
Just another texture of discomfort.
Another layer of numbness.
The library of unread books grew.
Freud's complete works sat unopened.
Their spines gathering dust like the subject's own intentions.
Productivity became a cult.
Twenty hours spent color-coding a to-do list.
Each task a false promise.
Each category a cage.
A podcast was started.
Three seconds of silence recorded, then abandoned.
A dinner party of cold soup, because warmth was too much effort.
And finally, the art of being boring.
An entire week spent talking about the weather, as if the sky were the only thing left worth
mentioning.
The loop was perfect.
No progress.
No regression.
Just the quiet hum of stagnation validated at last.
Stable.
Predictable.
Miserable.